[Applause]
lucky you interfere with now this paper
that you can in much
continue
bring down but every loss
it is written
it is their time to give penance
you are but one man
they are no longer your people for safe
[Music]
[Applause]
that was often this is awesome thank you
so so much
I'm Marty Stratton the executive
producer of doom eternal and I'm and I'm
Hugo Martin the game's creative director
as you just saw we're not just building
a world for Doom it's in the entire
universe earth is on the brink of
annihilation it's being consumed by
demons and your crusade to save it will
take you across dimensions to locations
never seen before in doom from heaven
and hell to the Sentinel homeworld and
beyond yeah
there is so much to see and discover but
doom is first and foremost about
gameplay and doom eternal promises to be
the ultimate power fantasy the fun comes
from mastering the experience because
you are the doom Slayer the strongest
fastest demon killer in existence and
nothing can stand in your way
of course the challenge in Doom is all
about handcrafted combat but also
engaging level design and in doom
eternal the game always has something
that's new to throw at you even deep
into the campaign let's take a look
[Music]
[Applause]
[Applause]
[Music]
thank you know it's it's so important to
us I did software that every aspect of
the gameplay has real meaning to you the
player every enemy is different every
weapon has a purpose and every decision
you make really counts the only path to
victory in Doom eternal is to
aggressively control the fight with
amazing agility powerful guns and
critical resources that's right I'll
tell you we absolutely can't wait for
you to play it and some of you won't
have to wait too long if you are lucky
enough to be in the room tonight you'll
have a chance to play it immediately
following the show
and for those not here but at e3 this
week we'll have doom eternal playable in
the Bethesda booth all week yeah but
enough talk let's see how it all comes
together and watch as this perfect
killing machine goes to work
[Applause]
charting a flight path to Mars
calculating thrust vectors jaqen three
for turbulence
[Applause]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
Thanks all right that was classic yeah
that was awesome Thanks we're so excited
because the gameplay that you just saw
is just a piece of what you're going to
play this week at e3 yeah but I've been
a lot of your wondering when do we get
to play Doom eternal at our home well
you don't have to wait too much longer
not quite tomorrow
[Applause]
but doom eternal will release on
November 22nd
we're very excited about that and we've
got something really special for Dhoom
fans an amazing collector's edition
we're really proud oh yeah yeah that's
that's an actual helmet yeah we you
could wear it you could wear that thing
this guy's Scott's already got it that's
right already about it either already
got one on all right well we've got one
more thing we know that you've been
waiting to hear about our totally new
doom multiplayer experience we call it
battle mode we've been developing this
in-house it did and it's unlike anything
you've played before
yeah we've been so pumped I did to share
this with you this is pure doom but with
your friends we're 2 player controlled
demons take on one fully loaded Slayer
in a fight to the death this is a
first-person fighter where it's demon
strategy versus Slayer skill you know we
can't wait because we know you'll love
the different playstyles of the various
demons because each has unique movement
attacks and abilities they can even
spawn AI demons to control the
battlefield and help you take down the
Slayer its strategic competitive and
it's a ton of fun and we can't wait to
share more details with you this year at
QuakeCon
that's right a lot more to share at
QuakeCon but before we go we do want to
take a first look at doom eternals new
multiplayer on behalf of our amazing
team at it in dallas and frankfurt
germany we want to thank you all so much
for your support thanks everyone
[Applause]
fight
[Music]
Slayer health critical
Slayer killed round two
[Music]
[Music]
final round fight
[Music]
[Applause]